[Music]
you
[Music]
hello everybody welcome to chess in the
Romantic era I'm gonna show you one of
some of the Bands games from Lowenthal
he was considered to be one of the best
players in the 19th century I do
remember in the two previous classes we
saw gains from Paul Murphy great
American chess player understand maybe
the best in the 19th century and what
else
one of his greatest rivals was Johan
Jacob wanted I think he was born in
Hungary but he spent a great part of his
life living in England Ethan
you know where is England exactly right
that's it
London beautiful city you should visit
it fish and chips okay so I'm going to
show you three games today let's see we
hope if we have time for that the first
game correspond to a game between
loewenthal with the white pieces under
tsin with the black pieces so let's
start a four E 5 9 f3 knight c6 and
Bishop c4 Kevin how this is called
Italian great it was very popular in
this century and the previous centuries
and it's just a very natural move right
with the ball of our piece and then
we're gonna go short Castle here the
bishop is place in the best diagonal
because we are putting pressure on the
f7 pole the weakest square and yeah so
Bishop c5 black does the same so people
from the YouTube you're more than
welcome to ask any questions
comments whatever and here
why played before a gambit that was very
common at that time you know how this
gambit is called Orlando you know the
name okay okay so this is cool yes so
this is called the Evans gambit and it's
extremely interesting because after
Bishop takes before now you play c3
winning a tempo and then you're gonna
play d4 and then you have a nice Center
and then this Queen can come also to b3
and then you are putting a lot of
pressure on the black keen side so here
there are different options Bishop a5 is
the most natural move so the idea is
that after d4 it takes you can take with
the pawn because there is something here
right right isn't it's happen that's the
name exactly I like this move so for
those who wants to learn some theory I
like this would be 7 the idea is that
after d4 you play Knight a5 it's a bit
weird but it's very interesting it looks
like blacks losing upon and it's true
after Knight takes e5 Knight takes e4
Knight takes e4 but in return you have
eliminated this dangerous Bishop and
then you're going to play d5 and black
enjoys the bishop pair again two bishops
versus one bishop on one night but okay
after c3 Bishop a5 it the most common
move what place d 4e takes d4 and now
since what's not able to take back on d4
long went out Castle kingside
sure castle and d6 basically what you
want to do with these t-6 you want to
develop this bishop later but also you
want to move this Knight to f6 so white
can't play e5 right which would be
extremely a
in this position so C takes d4 was
played bishop basics a really good move
it's prophylactic do you know what
prophylaxis is in chess it's a very
weird word right prophylaxis but what
does it even mean right
so prophylaxis means that instead of
focusing only in our own plans we first
think about what our opponent wants to
do and then we stop that and after that
we start thinking about our own our own
plans right so Bishop e6 is a
prophylactic move against Queen b3 Queen
b3 is what white wants to play here but
Bishop e6 fights against that because
after Queen b3 black is much better how
why do you think black plating that
[ __ ] would be six year and this is very
important because this piece should be
six is played many times in this move
and it has a reason there is a reason
here come on people from the YouTube
channel as well
next xt4 won't like texting for it's
really dangerous for example I guess I
can take and then Bishop f7 and this
looks really really dangerous for black
so it's not night sexy for bar instead
no Bishop takes d4 I check on f7 yes
somebody said it in the YouTube channel
Tom non-german and Andres Baba
not if I great Kevin you are too strong
today 95 the point is if white takes on
f7 you just move the King to f8 and then
there is no efficient way of protecting
this bishop right because if the Queen
comes to d5 how do you win the game now
black of course blacks move in here no
no no checkmate it's impossible to
checkmate since the king is well
protected here but you you're going to
win a piece
exactly so just is very simple
let's keep attacking pcs Knight f6 the
Queen has to go and the Queen can't
protect this Bishop let's say Queen g5
and then King f7 because with this
knight on a five you're removing these
two square from for the white player
right
that's why Bishop f7 is not possible so
Queen b3 there even though it looks like
the most natural mortality in f7 it's a
bad move here so a3 was played so
there's no pin on g4 and now Knight f6
was played by Anderson
Knight c3 by Lowenthal developing
appears protecting the center of pawn
right short castle was played and how do
you keep going here how do you develop
your piece where you want to put this
Bishop from c1 there there are many
possibilities here many decent
possibilities but what's the most
natural move here Bishop a3 it's
interesting but still this diagonal is
closed so Ruki 8 for example therefore
it's a good square too but for me I
would say g5 it's even more natural
right because there is a pin here right
so Bishop g5 was played by low Intel 86
by Anderson and now what do you play you
take an f6 you have any good reason to
give the bishop er no right if black had
to take with the palm would be a good
reason because we would be probably
destroying black's pawn structure and
the king would be not in a very safe
situation but since black can take with
the Queen we have no good reason to give
the bishop pair so that's why you should
go away let's say Bishop 8 4 this is
what low interplay and now G
I was played by Anderson it's an
important moment now we have two options
we can take on g5
we can go Bishop g3 what do we do it's
that's very reasonable so we are
sacrificing a piece and not only
destroying the pawn structure but there
is a a ping here with this knight on f6
and it's not easy for black to amping we
are just threatening to go an ID file
for example it's true that black can
take on d4 and this is actually what
happened in the game so for example if
black plays King g7 there is a beautiful
way of winning the game already what do
we play here with the white pieces it's
not that easy
I'm telling you guys most of you would
think about Knight d5 but then Bishop
t4i it's not that easy so how do we play
here
forcing moves captures threats threats
sorry and checks done if I take Queen a3
doesn't work I think because I can just
take on d4 with my knight if I and if I
take so you are saying if I take and
then you want to take back how about if
I just take on e5 Knight d5 Knight e4 I
think I can still survive here with
Queen D 1 it takes f6 and then let's say
King yet and still is not that easy but
the idea is really good if 5d takes e5
are now another what do we do how do we
exploit exploit this pin Queen f3 are
you threatening to take an f6 not really
right but with if you bring another
piece into the action that's a big hint
d5 is possible but I can just move my
knight Kevin you had a very good idea
you want it to take and then bring the
knight why you don't bring the knight
straight away 94 Black has to resign
right there's no efficient way of
protecting f6 you see the idea because
now the bishop after if I pawn takes
Knight takes the bishop even if comes d4
since the pawn is only 5 it can't
protect the the night from f6 right so
that's why King g7 loses in the game
under sin played Bishop takes e4 and now
Knight d5 do you think we can take the
rook on a1
I mean this move why there is a good
reason you're getting a rook that's a
good reason okay
but then something happens why cami
why there's a way this always away you
know what why means in Spanish why why
why why means school in Spanish why the
worldwide so it's like why why
alright so Bishop a1 it's not a good
move and why just Quint x a1 and then
you're gonna take this night to write
that was an easy one
I think there's nothing right for white
for black here you're taking and f6 with
the be shop or even with the night and
just wins so 95 was played um Bishop e6
was played by Anderson and here just a
very humble move route b1 was played but
it's not the humble because you see this
money over root P 3 and root 2 G 3 right
and it could be very very dangerous for
black what do you think now you can take
on D fiber not with the nidus obvious
right that you can because the Queen on
the edges there but can you take with
the bishop exactly because after it
takes if I you don't only lose that
Bishop C but also you're losing this one
because you have you got to remove this
night since it's it's being attacked and
then the bishop on d4 is just
unprotected right so you can't take on
d5 this is what black blue love to do
take on d5 so you remove another piece
that it's putting pressure and f6 right
here there was only one only way for
black to survive and it's really
beautiful
how do you survive here with the black
pieces
so you have any ideas so what would you
what should we do
which one this guy yeah but that's tough
yeah yeah somebody in YouTube more or
less found out the idea
the move is Knight takes d5 sacrificing
the Queen Bishop takes d8 and now Knight
c3 attacking the Queen so the Queen goes
to 85 and now you take on c4 and then we
got three pieces 1 2 3 4 the Queen and
sadly is not that obvious how to win the
game right and the rook is under attack
and the bishop is under attack exactly
exactly I think why it's only
possibility here is just to give checks
on the G file and the H file and just
make it wrong yeah so
you know Kevin anythin I will we will do
something funny at the end of the
lecture okay I'll tell you what later
right
you know how we celebrate checkmate in
Spanish commentary I'll tell you later
okay all right here the only chance for
white is to give checks on the G file on
the H file so this is like a draw but
after route b1 rook b8 was played by
under sin and now what do we play here
with the white pieces this game is
actually a brilliant game from Lowenthal
I really like it
Lowenthal was playing white yeah I like
that
you want to take the knight on f6 but
then that solves black's problem because
Sutton Bishop takes f6 there's no pain
anymore right so how do we bring more
pieces to the action yes
heavy pieces it should be 5 the problem
is okay that's not so bad
I think I can still play the same idea
Knight d5 and then Knight c3 something
like this but the move was route to b3
sorry route b3 we talked about this move
before we want to go to g3 and then this
kin is in deep trouble
right so King 87 was played and now how
do we finish black spawning this is just
very direct why to move yeah
yes captures checks and threats we want
to do that but there is a knight
protecting that square so that's that's
right
normally it would be better to take with
the bishop because then son rook is
going to come to this file to give a
check right so this is how low and tell
finish is upon it yeah you are like low
and tell ETA we can call you Ethan low
went oh yeah all right
so Bishop f6 Bishop f6 and now Ethan low
and tell finish your opponent come on
you said it just right now you set them
off no t3 okay that's interesting but
just said before Queen 85 check King g8
and now look to g3 Bishop g7 and one
more move no no because I just take it
so how do we threaten checkmate in one
move Kevin yeah no it's not checkmating
one way with this move we will be
threatening checkmate in one Queen
eight-six exactly somebody in the
YouTube channel said checkmate 64 and
Queen eight six and black has to resign
right because whatever black does next
move is Queen g7 it black goes Queen f6
then not f6 checkmate even more
beautiful with the night no because
there's a ping here you see it's an
illegal move it's an illegal move right
okay so this was the first game as you
can see was really beautiful with sonar
f6 right so Bishop f6 quickly yeah and
then King g8 probably is working after
rook g3 yeah and then let's say Bishop
g7 I don't know if it if okay at least
you can take the Queen yeah yeah it
works it works but the other variation
is just mate right okay so let's check
the second game from low Intel
okay so II for loewenthal again with the
white pieces against Brian normal so I
guess Brian and warm aware to players
you know before these players in the
Romantic era they used to play like the
good players versus a group of players
okay
they call it like consultation chess
they did yeah yeah it seems like
cheating right like I'm fair right but
you know they wanted to prove like they
were so good so that's why yeah
loewenthal was playing against two guys
yeah so Bishop e5 how this opening is
called yeah Bishop c4 is the Italian so
we should be five a country which is
very close to Italy
it could be Malaysia if I could be
Malaysia Australia very close to Italy
South Africa Morocco it's close but this
where am i from
so the Spanish company this is called
the Spanish real opeth opening we should
be v eh6 attacking the bishop Bishop a4
Knight of 6 sure castle and before we
check another game in the previous class
viewers choice we check that Knight e4
was possible I'm here black player they
went for that 94 rook e1 attack in the
night and night c5 attacking the bishop
right that's mark so you got to do
something about that so you take on c6
d take c6 and you get the pawn back
Knight e5 but ok this position nowadays
is considered to be okay for black after
the move 96 that's why you're not going
to see these opening in top tournaments
but ik here black played Bishop e6
that's a reasonable move - so there's no
check on the e-file right because white
was threatening knight c6 just winning
the game check and then taking the Queen
right so Bishop e6 and here
Lowe and child played a really
aggressive move Queen 85 what are you
threatening here with the white pieces
let's say if I play Bishop d6 just
developing my pieces what do you play
Kevin
Queen f7 world that's too much right
after Queen f7 I just tagged your queen
not f7 right there is a masked being
here on the e-file so you can't take
with the king it's illegal you can't
take with the bishop illegal move there
is a pin here wipe would be winning how
about after the move Bishop e7 it's a
bad move and you have to tell me why yes
so thus Knight f7 works now or not
Bishop f7 and then and then Orlando
exactly
so not f7 Bishop takes f7 and Queen
takes e5 and there is a pin here right
so I've taken Queen to h5 Queen f6 was
played in this position and then okay
black is protecting the f7 sorry the f7
pawn so night f7 is not possible anymore
because you will just take with the
Queen right Queen f7 and nothing happens
but now you are not controlling d4 right
so that's why low and tell use this to
play d4 before not only supports this
Knight but also attack this Knight and
also this Bishop is joining the party on
g5 right so 97 was played by Brian and
warm out and Bishop g5 what's the only
square fault black Queen here
great that's the only one level square
for the black queen
that's right I'm here white plate a very
good move what would you play here with
white I mean if you give me some time
I'll play probably eight six and then
you can move to Bishop since the queen
is unprotected so you gotta be careful
here in this position
[Music]
Oh
so you have any candidate moves or night
on d7 that's a possibility but then
after keen Texas seven I'm more or less
safe I'm planning to route to bring this
rook to e8 and then to castle
artificially so what moves Orlando Kevin
where 87 woo
what do you think about this move rook
takes 87 right and then you just lost a
queen don't blunder the Queen
Ethan mm-hmm what did you guys think
about this move matter of seven you
think that's a move
what do you play here with the black
pieces matter of seven is interesting
but it's not the best move in the
position sorry sorry
Queen takes an IED and you got boom
Ruki six I'm white wins but how about g6
did you say that but then your queen is
attacked too so
SILS you got nine eight six only moved
to survive here the only move just what
you wanted to play Kevin Queen it's free
whoo then I take here and then I take
their blacks apiece up right yeah that
was so suppose ability so let's say Matt
f7 g6 Queen h4 but then I just take the
knight on f7 and blacks better so
there's a better move did anybody of you
saw them Orlando yes exactly that was a
brilliant move by Lowenthal g4 and Ethan
what's the only square available for
black now
we've got people here in the YouTube
channel from on dudas you know we're in
the race is different it's actually
pretty close to to your country Central
America where you want to go do exactly
so you can go there you can't go there
no there no there no there no there no
there not here but then exactly you can
take the pawn on c2 but now these runs
into night to f7 boom a 6 g 6 this is
what black players played here g6 but
now Lowenthal sacrifice the Queen he
played night - h8 taking the rook she
takes 8 5 rook takes is 6 the point is
he this King can go to f7 or d8 so you
have to sacrifice another piece right
route take c7 King f8 and now it's time
to count to count so we got one route
one rook one night one night so black
has sorry White has one rook and two
pieces for a queen and that's a good
business for the white player 93 was
played
tuck in the queen winning a temple and
black to can be to Rukh a II won and now
black took on a three Luke takes d7 and
now black played Queen eight three rook
f7 King g8 and now how do you finish
like like player here Kevin II Kevin
what do you play here with the with the
white pieces be careful because I want
to take your knife yeah who saw that
Ethan do you think you saw that yeah
exactly so that will be perfect yeah BB
checkmate but life is not that easy
life's never easy so make it easy
rookie seventh then that runs into queen
g4 followed by Queen g5 oops
I wait we got all the time
perfect
that's a brilliant move Luke III only
move for black here is to take the pawn
on g4 and now root 2 G 3 and that
they're gonna be a lot of discover
checks Queen d1 was played King G -
Quinn taxi for and now Kevin Bishop
where now it's actually anywhere are you
sure I'm not so sure because I have six
just wins in the spot yeah but Bishop h6
can I just play King h8 Bishop g7 and
now King g8 I was thinking about this
position okay yes Bishop g4 even wins
you're a piece up but but Bishop f6 just
wins straight away right Bishop f6 you
are forced to play queen g4 and then you
just win this position you can even take
and you're a pizza okay piece up pizza
yeah we are all hungry right
it's eight yeah me too man
we got to finish the class in 15 minutes
and then time for dinner
all right so last game last game and
then this is the same game yes this is
the same game that we just saw right so
we're not gonna see that a game so I
think it's this is the game that I had
prepared again no went out with the
white pieces against Joseph Senn he 45
96 Italian Bishop c5 before we thought
the Evans gambit and now we're gonna see
c3 very natural move aiming to install a
center with d4
d 6 today it is well known that Knight
f6 is the best move here in the position
but they didn't have databases stating
half books or even tournaments so this
was like in 1842 this game d6 was played
d4 installing a nice Center he takes you
for C takes e4 Bishop d6 again Kevin and
Ethan what happens after Queen b3 we
guess so that this is a transposition
actually
[Music]
exactly Knight to a5 that's right
so we b3 not not a good move a tree was
played not f6 sure Castle and now here
just have played eight six prophylaxis
against Bishop g5 so it's it's nighty
for possible here
yes a rookie 1t5 only move on now what
do you play here with white what what do
you take
and then Queen takes there's actually a
big difference between 92 and 93 because
of the 92 a player 5 and I'm happy
Knight c3 the point is you're also
attacking the Queen right so f5 is no
longer possible because we take the
Queen right so so so so 94 it's actually
a mistake because after d5 then Knight
c3 and then what's better we're taking
the e4 Knight with a check right ok so
short Castle 8 6 was played Knight c3
sure castle and now a 3 was played in
this position 94 was possible actually
here after Knight takes d5 and blacks ok
but instead Joseph played not a very
good move
he went fortnight to 87 here in this
position do you normally don't want to
go to the corners right with your pieces
right I'm here no Intel also improves
his Knight he wants to bring this Knight
to g3 looking for some more action this
Knight can jump to f5 can jump to 85
also protect protects efore 97 was
played by Jobson Knight f4 Knights c6
sorry aiming to go d5 in this position
and Bishop b3 was played prophylaxis
against against again sorry so after d5
has happen in the game you want to close
with E 5 and now we have a nice pawn
majority here on the key inside that
Lowenthal is going to
later piece of sea salmon was played
here by Joseph and Bishop see to this
this Bishop has done his job on this day
are not not that their honor but this
diagonal now this diagonal is closed so
that's why you want to bring the bishop
to c2 and then there could be some
potential attacking chances on the Kings
side after sun queen d3 right so that's
why now black tries to trade to trade
sorry this important piece that the
bishop on c2 that was extremely
dangerous Bishop takes a 590 xf v and
queen d3 attacking this Knight Queen d7
was played protecting this night and now
how do you connect the rook the rooks
how do we connect the rooks Kevin
how do we continue development Bishop d2
right we want to bring this truck to the
action 97 was played maybe not the best
move going back again and now rook a to
c1 was played by Lowenthal rook F to e 8
and now g4 he starts attacking on the
key inside maybe this night can also
jump to 85 d4 supports this knight
Knight FA was played and night at five
what's the threat here so let's say for
example black plays a 5 what do we play
here with the white pieces there are
some tactical problems here for the
white for the black player yes anybody
has an idea
exactly Sergio Caballero found out also
hi there mirmix Bishop 86 and now after
G takes Knight f6 nasty Fork check and
then I'll take the Queen right Ethan you
understand yeah you get the point now
I've seat checks you got to move the
King and then 90 67 okay great so that's
why black played Queen ecig so now
Bishop 86 doesn't work because you can
take with the Queen but 984 by Lowenthal
now he wants to send the f1 to the
action f4 f5 is a really important
threat here in this position and
actually there's no efficient way of
stopping this because you can never move
this cheap one since there is a fork on
f6 now attacking the rook and the king
so Kimmy chain was played and boom F 4 F
6 + f5 the Queen has to go to f7 and
here what's the simplest the simplest
way of winning material here is 6 I go
back to g8 probably it's also very good
but there's just a very simple way of
winning upon
yes
g7 that's losing a piece right because I
can take with the Queen so that's not
very good right exactly so simple chess
captures what do we capture Kevin sorry
he takes f6 great G takes f6 and now
Bishop takes 8 6 this is how the King
continued and now 97 was played Bishop
g7 check keen 87 and Queen to d2 as you
can see now the Queen wants to come to
86 and then 88 and that's checkmate
right so what can we do to stop that 9
g8 Black is trying to defend this
position it's really tough
low and I'll play Knight g6 bring in
another piece to the action yes Knight
f7
not of six how about if I just take yeah
I know what you wanted to do you wanted
to do after night g2f six queen eight
six right and then queen eight shape but
black can't take with the other night be
careful in these positions we are so
close to the victory that we don't want
to mess up ninety-six rookie four was
played and the Queen can't come to 86 so
that's why Lowenthal decided to find
another route queen f 2 followed by
Queen 84 and it's just impossible for
black to stop White's attacked right 97
was played sorry Queen 2 8 4 and now
King g8 was played you take here on g6
you just can take and if the Queen takes
Knight f4 check and then you win the
Queen so that's why after King g8 what
do what what do you play here with the
white pieces come on this is the last
part of the class you should find the
best continuation for white here
yes come in be careful you only got one
one shot Kinji 7ha kim taek's Kintex of
knight on f6 kim takes f6 so sonar e6
King g7 Queen eight seven keen f6
come on come in your pizza is waiting
what you're gonna eat
what are you gonna eat you don't know
something good hopefully yeah if aunt
tell me but then I can just take right
or even with my queen
yeah so anybody site Orlando you saw
that Kevin you were doing all right
you started pretty well yeah sure Tinh
takes 98 Luke takes and you'll resign
I do when I go back to age five then
King g8 so Wesley so Bishop f6 are you
thinking about after Bishop f6 I guess I
can take on g6 yes probably is still
winning but but there is a fourth
continuation here for C moves for C
moves checks all the time
Kevin check me not f6 King g7 continuing
continuing you were doing fine before
continue one more check and you have
there one more check one more come on
five seconds are you sure if an you know
it's this position now how you win just
one more check come on
Kevin you got you got it just one more
check give me one more check you know
what to do that sorry Queen h4 I just go
back to g7 no give me another check you
know how to do that check come on come
on there's just two checks in the
position yeah yeah I'm then and then
what happens with the Queen and f7 yeah
yeah don't want check and then you win
the game
g5 that's a move King takes only move on
Queen takes f7 and black can resign
right and this is how Laurent I'll
finish the game okay guys so these were
the three games that I wanted to show
you Lo and tile was a really great
player this has been my last lecture
here and this year in st. Louis and
going back to Spain tomorrow so thank
you for coming and hopefully see you
soon in the future you guys thank you
okay Kay Kevin Ethan you want to
celebrate her Spanish commentary no yes
or no come here come on here you have to
appear in the in the show yeah if I come
on here Kevin like we normally okay come
on here Ethan come on okay let's go
come on here yeah come on here you know
like a much harlech a machine gun sounds
grata Dada Dada Dada Dada somewhat J's
checkmate
alright in some top tournament we
celebrate like that we just look at the
camera and say come on do it
come on the song that's right great okay
thank you guys
you